maniac is a 2018 limited Netflix series
starring Emma Stone and Jonah Hill the
TV show has a lot to unpack and
throughout this video I'll be discussing
the show's ending and multiple reveals
there will be heavy spoilers so it may
be worth skipping this video for now if
you want to watch the programme with
fresh eyes without the way I'm
definition and I ruin the show so you
don't have to maniac follows characters
Annie and Owen as they take a range of
psychoactive pills that produce
hallucinations the hallucinations range
from grounded visions to the absurd and
each pearl produces a different version
of reality the three pills represent
several realities and each one has a
deeper meaning to it pill a is the drug
that Annie was addicted to before
participating in the experiment and
through the visions she receives we are
able to experience the most dramatic
moment of their life the death of her
sister pill B is where things start to
interconnect for the characters and to
me this pill represents the lies that
people tell themselves in order to
escape reality after severe trauma the
two characters are initially a Long
Island couple before they manifest as
1940s con artists both characters commit
evil and ugly deeds that signify how
grief can cause anger that corrupts if
not kept in check and pel B is one of
the most interesting aspects of the show
pill C is by far the most important for
both characters and it puts them in
situations where they are forced to
confront their own mistakes and deal
with them in a Lord of the Rings satire
Annie is tasked with protecting a
weakened princess as they travel to a
water source which has healing
properties
in contrast Owen is a gangster that
struggles with remaining loyal to his
family and the character is forced to
confront her version of Olivia who in
the real world once provoked a psychotic
episode for him they are eventually
thrust into us by thriller which
concludes the vision pill C is
ultimately about conference
to acceptance of reality even though we
push ourselves to extremes to forget the
princess clearly represents any sister
and showcases that we all make mistakes
however confronting them and accepting
their mother only way to truly move on
and grow in the end the trial is
ultimately shut down but that doesn't
mean that it was a waste of time the
doctor that created the experiment
exclaims that it was a great success and
that all were healed in an interview
with thrill list Patrick Somerville who
worked on the show stated that while the
pills may not be the right idea I think
what happens in the show is that the
trial forces a lot of people to spend
time together and talk to each other
about who they are and how they feel
something about that works so for the
ending we just wanted to tell a story of
radical acceptance about people
accepting themselves and seeing that new
friendships and new connections to other
people can come out of that if you can
get to the place where you can accept
certain things about yourself to me the
experiment should be seen more as that
there are pubic experience and welds the
characters face death several times they
came out stronger because of it in the
end it results in a conclusion that
builds a relationship between Annie and
Owen that helps them to aid each other
in moving beyond the traumatic elements
in their life in the final shots of the
series Owen is at a treatment facility
which is when Annie busts him out and
despite his reservations he goes with
her they make their escape laughing
which showcases that even though they
have been through hell they have still
managed to come out the other side with
a smile on their face
[Music]
so what did you think of maniac did you
enjoy the show and what was your
favorite hallucination comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please like it and subscribe to my
channel I create ending explain videos
like this weekly and they'll definitely
be something on here that you love if
you're a fan of television again thanks
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you